I hate intros kwangji Gaucho episode 1
great kick things off with the
introduction of the most popular MMO
game glory and the most popular player
in glory gates you who is known as the
god of fighting Jew is signed to the
professional team excellent air as the
team captain because he was so good he
leads the team to three championship
victories and creates a name for himself
as the best player but the past couple
of years haven't worked out we are
introduced to soo muchas goes to attend
a meeting with shoe and the excellent
era management to discuss the future of
the team the management blame shoe for
the recent failure so they're gonna
bring in a new player soon she young to
replace him as the captain they are also
gonna strip him of his character and
give it to Shyam while shoe is gonna be
moved down to a training partner he
doesn't want to do that he wants to
actually play so instead he insists that
they terminate his contract which
unfortunately comes with termination
fees apparently shoe had helped people
with money in the past while also
denying sponsorship so he's on that
financial struggle they offer to waive
the fees if he signs a contract
announcing his retirement which he does
because he has no other choice side note
once players do this they can't come out
of retirement for one year on his way
home he decides to go to an internet
cafe where he meets Chen Guo he ends up
asking if he can become a night
supervisor since she is the boss of the
internet cafe and she agrees if he pulls
an all-nighter that night just so
happens to be the launch of the new
tenth server so a lot of people are
starting fresh with new characters while
getting ready for the launch he tries
telling her that he's actually gay Chu
from excellent era but she writes this
off as a lot we've had server launches
and he is on that low-level grind with
the trash quest to get started on his
new characters you motion he gets a new
weapon the myriad manifestation umbrella
which he seems determined to get
upgraded a random player sleeping moon
invites him to a raid were they gonna
split the loot through dice rolls during
the raid Xu picked up on the fact that
sleeping moon is throwing all the other
party members under the bus so that he
could take all the loot for himself once
he notices she stops healing him and
plans to kill the raid boss without
anybody else's help episode 2 after the
other party members died he solos the
boss and takes all the rare loot the
Tropic is that sleeping moon at spread
the rumor that shoot was actually the
one who was trying to take all the loot
from the beginning so he ends up getting
a bad reputation for this he runs back
in at the same party full moon guilt and
ask them if they want to party up again
which takes some convincing but they
eventually agree and he ends up soloing
another shadow cat everyone's impressed
so they continue on to the spider cave
where he continues to flex and gets them
the first kill of the spider cave on the
tenth server they run into a hidden boss
so Shu coordinates with the rest of the
party giving them orders on how to fight
it securing the first kill on the hidden
boss
well we jump over to a different guild
blue brook who gets notified that shoe
had gotten to first kills and they're
desperate to get first kills for their
reputation so Blue River tries to friend
in Blue River explains to him that
they're desperate for first kill so
schewe says that he's gonna help them if
they agree to give him a list of rare
materials back in real life Coyle gives
him a place to stay at the internet cafe
so we crashes and when he wakes up
everybody starts getting the news that
he's gonna be retiring all of glory is
pretty shaken up about this especially
guó who is a huge fan episode 3 he again
tries explaining to go that he's
actually a Jew but she still doesn't
believe him jump in game and she was
going on the raid with the blue Brook so
that he can get the rare materials that
they promised him they go to clear huge
mob of goblins that usually come some
ways but he's planning on gathering all
of the waves together and killing them
all at once it's pretty much the same
formula as the last raid the party
doubts him he starts flexing how ope is
and then they come around during the
fighting they figure out that he's
actually using the adventure profession
which is the beginner profession that
everybody moves away from so they're
confused as to why he's still using it
he lures all the goblins and at once and
blue Brook members make quick work of
them setting the new speed record for
the frost force raid woe brings her
friend Tom Rua to the cafe where she
flaunts her skills in front of a crowd
and wins glow some games rural claims
that the game is too easy so gloves
suggest going against you they go had a
head for a bit and people start to
realize that he's actually Lord Grimm
the star of the tenth server anyways he
slaughters her and she keeps you're
challenging him over and over just to
lose again she's never been beaten like
this before so she wants to get better
to catch up to shoot Gemma sold for ruo
decides to create a new character after
losing to Shu well recommends battle
mage because that's why yay - played as
on excellent era where you find out that
the reason she plays classless is
because his custom weapon makes it Opie
where she finds out that rule is gonna
be playing a battle mage he makes her
some videos to help teach her how to
play the class the world bows blood
gunner makes his appearance so the top
three guilds blue Brook herb garden and
tyrannical ambition go there to secure
the first kill while the guilds are
arguing amongst themselves a brawler
named steamed bun invasion shows up with
shoo and starts fighting with the boss
the guilt see that she was gonna be able
to kill the boss so they start trying to
bribe him to join their group so they
can get first kill credit he ignores
them so they all go in to try and KS the
boss she orders his group to retreat and
once they're clear he and rages the
blood gunner so it spawns 100 zombies
that keep the three guilds busy
meanwhile he lures blood gunner away to
full moon' guilt so that they can all
fight the boss and get the first kill on
it yeah after that blue river writes him
and once this helped to beat the frost
force record again but he says that he
already agreed to help tyrannical
ambition
in the last scene shoe gets a
notification that his record in frost
force raid got smashed by seven minutes
by excellent dynasty which is excellent
IRA's guild episode five she was gonna
be helping blue brook retake the record
with the party he's putting together the
next night excellent era has a match
against team 301 jewel watches the 3v3
match where they go 1v1 until one side
runs out of players soon as young beats
the first two by itself and is fighting
the last member of team 301 without
needing the help of his two teammates
Shu speculates that this is because team
301 is throwing the 3v3 match so that
Zhang doesn't perform as well in the 5v5
jump ahead to the five e5 and Shawn gets
caught up in a fight with the grind King
and can't get out of it which I'll try
is helping from a distance but is
intercepted because of Shawn's poor team
play and they end up losing creamy Leo
how the vice-captain for excellent era
and the one responsible for breaking the
record in frost forest he goes into the
cafe and finds she working there power
doesn't like shoe because he was always
yelled at by him when she was on
excellent era they argue a bit with shoe
saying that how should have controlled
Chung during the match and then he kicks
him out to beat the new record in frost
force shoe gets rule and steamed bun
invasion the dumb brawler to help him
and the surprise member helping them is
sumo Chun the gunner from excellent era
he episode six
eventually they help tyrannical ambition
set the new record of 13 minutes five
seconds beating out excellent dynasty
excellent dynasty responds back beating
the record again and retaining the best
time house suspects that it's highly
probable that Lord Grimm is actually
shoe so he makes an account to sabotage
him he friends him under the name
hateful sword to spy on him shoe ends up
allowing him to do a bone yard run with
them to try and set the new record prior
to the run shoe had devised a new
strategy to easily achieve the new
record time for the boneyard dungeon
meanwhile excellent era and blue reign
have an official match where how gets
bodied by huang shan because he was
focusing too much on his sabotage this
ends up costing Icelandair the match but
despite his loss he still wants to get
back at you how an excellent dynasty
sealed the plan that she would made and
use it to set the new boneyard record Xu
had to figure it out the hateful sword
is actually how so he tells him that
he's been exposed and how dips later
Huang Xiao Tian the vice captain of blue
reign that just dumps turd how on their
match satisfied the cafe in full-on
incognito mode Haman Scheuer friends and
go way back so he greets to help with
the record Zhu explains his plan of
trapping monsters as well as the second
boss in a crack which will allow them to
save time
pretty sure streamers these days will
get banned for this on twitch but who
knows what their band inconsistencies in
the last scene everybody meets up with
blue brook and get ready to break the
boneyard record he eva's o7 chu and the
team are able to beat the record by 32
seconds and how finds out that Xiao Tian
was actually helping them in the race
chatzi an ass shoe why he retired and he
explains what happened he goes into a
little bit more detail and saying that
the reason he didn't transfer Dame's is
because mu Chun would have terminated
her contract to follow him so we retired
instead woo Chung's contract is over in
a year and a half so that's when he's
planning on returning to the pro scene
later on while she was training with Rua
and steamed bun they get attacked by the
herb guarded leader plan to go seed sure
when planting a seed square off and she
winds up winning of course but during
the fight he had realized that the
player using planting a seed was
actually Wayne GX she which is the
captain of the competitive team tiny
herb in response to his loss she tells
the members of the tiny herb to go and
kill shoo they come in force and sure
doesn't have a choice but to fight him
off which he makes it look easy at this
point she says like he's eighty percent
sure that Lord Grimm is actually yay to
the greatest boss in history hitting the
last scene we get a quick look at the
team Sam Serra captain and the champion
of last season's glory tournament shall
sekai no episode 8 chui continues
training with herb garden which is also
helping him level up Lord Grimm in the
process he suggests a new format of
training instead of fighting them in
groups like he's been doing he's gonna
do with them one on one but the addition
is that every time they want to duel
with him they have to be broooo in a
duel first he makes this condition so
that rule can get the practice says she
needs against the pro players
the second condition for dueling with
him is that they have to bet rare
materials so that he can continue
upgrading their gear one of the tiny
herb players Chad Yvan goes against ro
and it takes him a bit to win so he gets
flame about the team bullies xiaoyun
yeah after the fight with Roo he is able
to go against Shu but before they fight
Shu suggests that the ghostblade class
might be more of a fitting to his
playstyle
now it's time for sure to go against the
captains exe but this time he's gonna be
on his main character they have an epic
fight where gxg is pushed to his limits
but the fight ultimately ends in a draw
later on ruh-oh mentioned says she was
impressed with her during the duel so he
offered her a position in the tiny herb
training division but she turned him
down
if von decides to take shoes of ice and
creates a new ghost play character then
the next day we finally get to meet the
player behind steamed bun invasion bow
wrong she never sewed not a lot of
guilds are upset with you because he set
up a deal with full moon guild to set a
record in the desolate land of jade for
a really cheap price the guilts keep
trying to bribe him with offers to help
them instead in are irritated that he's
turning them down because he agreed to
help full moon first he follows through
on his word and sets the new record in
the dungeon with full moon blue Brook
feel like their reputation is being
threatened since they're losing to such
a small guilt like full moon because of
this blue Ripper is forced to go to the
heavenly dome an to get advice from the
main leader changing spring meanwhile
shoe roam cheek and rural go shopping
for new weapons well bartering shoe
notices that some players are following
it jump over to desolate lands wrong she
notices that somebody's following them
again so he goes to attack them with his
new claw weapon it's actually Talia Phan
on his new ghost plate account but wrong
Jeanne had noticed somebody else before
a bunch of guiltless players ambushed
the four of them and they all start
fighting giving Yvonne the chance to
practice teamfights with this new
character we see that the three major
guild leaders are watching from a
distance suggesting that they're not the
ones responsible for this attack even
though there are numbered with the
coordination of the strategies from Shu
they're still able to win when blue
river wants to talk with the main guilt
later he sent popular beach over to the
tenth server to help break the desolate
land record turns out he has other plans
and wants to fight with you but ends up
getting to be won by shoe and buns
losing the fight they even though we've
lost that fight blue Brook still managed
to beat the desolate land records later
after the fight changing spring the main
leader for the blue Burke meets with Shu
who tells him that they would have done
better in the dungeon if blue river was
leading it instead of popular Beach
making blue rivers heart flutter still
nobody is sure who the group was that
launched the initial ambush on Shu jump
over the excellent error building were
chatting you who is raging got his
computer suggesting that they were the
ones responsible this guy has a problem
with Shu because when he tried to go pro
he was shot down so we blamed Shu
because he was captain at the time
well chatting with chief on Shu tells
him that they can beat the desolate land
records but they're gonna need his ghost
blade he episode Poplar Beach had been
wanting to 1v1 with Chu so he finally
agrees and wins while playing on bows
gunner account the captain of blue
brained Yu wen Zhao is watching the
match and after thinking about it for a
bit figures out that it's actually Shu
playing he also did after that his
teammate Huang Shan had helps Shu set
the boneyard record and the hell was
hateful blade spying on Shu John was
trying to hide this from his captain but
when Chaz powers of deduction are too
Opie jump on over to row who comes
across a dungeon guide by an unknown
player named concealed light Chelsey
iMessages Shu to let him know that when
Zhao had figured out his identity and
now he wants to duel with him Shu agrees
and fights against one Xiao who was
using his warlock main when Zhao is
known for having a slower APM and relies
more on his game sense to carry his
fights which isn't enough and he loses
to Shu but afterwards while they're
talking he tells you that the
unspecialized will likely lose its early
level advantages once he gets to around
level 95 later on she takes an interest
in the concealed light player who wrote
the dungeon guide
even though he's a noob to glory he
figured out how to make a guide from his
imagination
rushan comes by later said that they
could play together but while playing
they figure out that all their members
are being targeted Andrew was killed he
episode 11
well fleeing from attackers wrong
cheating runs into conceal blight the
guy who wrote the Dungey guides who was
looking for him Rong Jing is able to
escaped with the help of concealed bike
giving him directions once they get a
chance wrong Jean contact Xu who tells
him to go to congee for a saint consoled
light taxol wants to tell him to save
this path Xu is being chased by a mob of
players and we find out that this is
actually a joint operation between
multiple guilds led by Yahoo weed - slow
down shoot fields taking part in the
operation our excellent dynasty herb
garden samsara misty castle blossom
Valley and void walk blue river was also
invited but he ended up turning him down
while fleeing from the mob she was
spammed at by Xiao Tian who is wanting
to do with him Xu agree said that also
he tells him to come to the forests as
well when Xiao Tian arrives at the
forest he is also targeted by the mob so
she tells him that he's gonna have to
fight him chatty I just wants to fight
with you until one of the players calls
him trash because he's only level 27 so
we dumpsters a guy and his friend while
taking one of their swords
after that he sets his sights back on Xu
but they get interrupted again by more
mobs their friends pretty well against
the mobs would eventually start running
low on mana and are surrounded by the 18
remaining members this conveniently
queues the entrance of MU Chung rogue
chinkyu Fong rule and concealed light
who all show up to help them fight in
the end this is enough to fight off all
the guilds despite being outnumbered
episode 12 the guilds are persistent and
trying to prevent Xu and the others from
leveling by keeping them out of the
dungeons but this isn't gonna be enough
to stop them Joe decides to go for the
wild bias of lion Canyon that just
appeared
meanwhile the leader of tyrannical
ambition goes to the tyranny
headquarters to ask the captain of the
tyranny pro team han wen Qing for help
with Xu the captain is busy so he has to
talk to Jiang Zi CA who is the vice
captain of tyranny after watching some
of Lord Grimm CA plays Jean Shay says
that it's probably a true playing when
they present this to one Chang he
doesn't believe them so they're giving
server 10 accounts to go find out the
tyranny members skirmish with Chu for a
bit and then when cheek steps in to
fight it we get a little backstory on
when Qing and Chu from 9 years ago where
they were both undefeated in arena and
about to have a duel we don't see who
wins but we jump ahead just a bit where
Xu and excellent era defeat wen Qing and
tyranny in the first glory tournament
back to the present even though nobody
wants a fight she was sure is one Qing
that he's gonna return to the pro scene
in the last scene after the credits Kuo
had gotten some uniforms for the members
which made me realize I hate outros